how're you guys going fire fire
I'm happy to be here man love my brother
my brother's transgender he transitioned
from a woman to a man years ago and he
loves his body and I'm very happy he
loves his body
he loves the body so much he loves to
brag about it to me
he'll come ot man look man I got more
facial hair than you I got more armpit
hair than you I didn't know he
transitioned into an [ __ ] it was like
I'm happy for you but you ain't gotta
flex on me no I felt like I feel like
the ended a Little Mermaid like the
murmurs I think what's up areas like oh
you bet you still got flippers you're
still in the water we just want to say
hi
I got sneakers all right girl look we
just want to tell you go visit your
father love you can't [ __ ] bye
aerials are dig I love my brother man I
always have love for him and the LGBTQIA
community man for real dawg like I love
them so much and I hope they get the
representation to mainstream that they
deserve to the point
I hear them make in a black panther too
and I hope in this movie the Black
Panther finally finally acknowledges his
brother the Pink Panther hey I think
it's time I think it's sound cuz if I
could do what he could do it Cano during
the first movie his brother was back
there like so y'all not gonna let me
fight okay okay
I made your outfits all right what kinda
okay I got it
I get it
I recently got engagement love my fiance
a lot we said thank you thank you thank
you thank you
I'm glad you believe me cuz I have
nothing to show for you know like when
she's a gay she has the ring feel like
you engaged she's like BAM and B I'm
like yeah go look Oh her hair I did that
I got love marriage and love I just
think it needs much more equality like
if I propose in two weeks
I should get some engagement sneakers so
I could feel that joy she feels so I'm
walking down the street my boys I know
you got engaged yes yes she with the
Nike me and my fiance we have a adopted
cat named Libby love her very much whoa
it's her cat her cat likes me so I'm
honored because that cat that's the only
animal you don't pick them they pick you
every time I would pair she would move
out the way will circle back
stop being thirsty all the cats all the
cats make you feel like Anne Hathaway in
there Meryl Streep from The Devil Wears
Prada hey Libby how you doing here why
is the cat food not ready
it's never ready love adopting animals
man I really do I love I love the
expression on their face they always had
that expression like thank you so much
you don't know what I do the kid you
like I want to know they story like I
really wish we could pour a little
whiskey and they water they drink the
water then grab a cigarette seeing your
couch I'll tell you my story
you call me Libby that's not my name and
I'm Nora Davis thank you so much
[Applause]